foreign
[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts the comedy Mothership in Austin
Texas this club it's too hard to resist
shout out to Joseph Rogan everything is
utter Perfection it's perfect it's a
perfect Club perfect Vibe it just runs
so right it's amazing it's so state of
the art the club is just fantastic it's
the best club in the country best sound
I've ever heard the most beautiful Club
that's ever been imagined it's already
the greatest Club I've been in the
layout the seating The Green Room the
sound system top notch it was almost
like it was
a comedy club designed by a comedian who
has unlimited money what he has created
is insane he's like the new version of
Mitzi Shore on behalf of my mom too I'm
so proud of you it reminds me of like
the gray clubs in the country it's The
Comedy Store of steroids that's all I
could say
Aerosmith is Aerosmith Guns and Roses is
Aerosmith on steroids if you really
think about him just one level of more
explosions this is what this comedy
mothership is
it's for the comic there's a lot of
comedy clubs that you go to and they
never thought about the comedian they
never thought about a green room I
didn't realize it was going to be like
this like he said it you know like
somebody can say something right but
saying it and then actually seeing it
like it's perfect to live in Austin
because when I'm not on the road I can
still do headline of time you know what
I'm saying right like since the club is
open I did like 18 spots it is the best
situation for a comic to be in is to
have access to Austin Texas right now
yes congratulations to Joe Rogan and uh
the ceremony has officially started for
comedians from all over the country
going down there and kiss the rig
that's what you got to do you gotta
gotta cook you gotta kiss the rig baby
he's a benign King he's the best it's a
perfect Club perfect Vibe it actually
feels like it's been open forever it has
I I was just in there like oh this feels
like it's been here for such a long time
because it was designed by somebody who
had been performing in comedy clubs for
so long and just took all the best parts
of it from a comedian's perspective and
created it for comedians I'm not gonna
even just mince words here that's the
greatest Comedy Club I've ever been in
and I've been in some great ones I don't
even know where to begin all I can tell
is when you go in that place you can
tell that every [__] thing on the
wall on the floor on the sailing sight
lines everything in that place
was painstakingly gone over
to make sure that it was absolutely
perfect and that's what I kept telling
Joe he goes how do you like the club and
I was like dude it is [__]
perfect
it's [__] perfect the colors of the
boots mitzi's place I think that's what
it's called the bar downstairs
um the main room the smaller room I only
did I did two I did set Saturday and
Sunday there in the smaller room and I
love that place in uh Harlan Williams
what do you say there freckles he was
there in the main room so I got to see
him the Green Room
the food the whole thing was amazing and
I knew that he would have this option I
was like if a comedian is designing the
club he's going to have the option that
you can either deal with the crowd or
not deal with the crowd meaning when
your set is over if you want to go out
and talk to the crowd AKA you had a good
set
[Laughter]
or maybe maybe you didn't maybe you
pissed a few people off and when you go
behind the curtain you just want to stay
there and you can get to the Green Room
without having to deal with anybody it
is [__] amazing and the club also had
open mic night
which is something that went away during
my stand-up career it was how an open
mic night was crucial well I can't say
Joe absolutely [__] picked the
perfect venue and crushed it it's
unbelievable cool week did uh Rogan's
Club all week yeah it was pretty [__]
cool dude that was probably all and then
uh I was the first person to stand up on
the he has two rooms so I got to go
first and it was just me and Dave
Chappelle hey which room the small room
too how was that [__] awesome
that room is it's like about 150 people
yeah small what'd you guys each do I did
like 20 and then brought him on and he
he did his thing he didn't go that long
he only did like an hour God it was
[__] wonderful God damn it but I
didn't do that good what do you think of
cold open go first oh I wasn't I wasn't
loose because everybody was in there
watching including [__] Dave
Chappelle Rogan introduced me and Dave
Chappelle was in that it was dude I'd
[__] it was a scary one I jump off
stage yeah
yeah it was uh pretty neat Paulie Shore
how's he doing he [__] murdered it
was hilarious dude that's a false but he
murdered I was like God damn I mean how
much I mean you allowed to say how much
money spent on it yeah well I'm allowed
to say it no you don't say it no okay
well you spent he spent a lot you spent
a lot of money on it yeah and those two
stages when you pay construction people
yeah no I I I get it but they did a
great job it was they [__] nailed it
were there two stages before or yes yes
there was two they had converted it when
they converted it to the movie theater I
think that's when they turned it into
two rooms this thing that's happening
you know and obviously I've been in it
my whole life
you know since I was four yeah and you
know and it's um you know first of all
I'm so proud of you you know I have I I
see you sometimes and we give each other
hugs I say I love you and but I don't
get to say how proud I am of you I've
seen you my whole you know for years and
and um you know on behalf of my mom too
you know because
um I know how much you love her and I
know how much she means to you
and I know how far you've come I know
how far you've come because I remember
when you first stepped at the store and
I remember seeing you in Boston and I
remember because we're the same age and
we came up at the same time yeah and I'm
so proud of you dude when I say it's
it's different from every comedy club
I'm talking about all the little things
the the you know the layout the seating
The Green Room the sound system
top-notch you know all the little things
that a club that a normal club might
have to go cheap on or skimp on or maybe
not necessarily get the best thing on
this club don't is not restricted by any
of that so everything is the best it can
be as far as at least at least it's the
best that
the people working for Joe know of the
sound that Joe Rogan's is [__]
phenomenal they are high these people
that are working there are high like
they're [__] not high on weed or high
on drugs but it's a high to working now
they've been telling me who's been going
in there the last two weeks it's like
[__] endless who goes in there from
Bill Burr to Dean Del Rey the [__]
Roseanne Barr I mean it's just the
people Dave Chappelle some [__]
people from Sports World were down there
last week just to watch the comedy show
somebody from Memphis or something the
way it's set up it's it's set up to
Foster new Talent too it's not just set
up to take care of existing Talent it's
set up so that you create a nice comedy
environment where people can go and see
guys like Shane Gillis you guys like you
guys go up see guys like Greg
Fitzsimmons or you know um Schultz was
here last week it was [__] amazing
the club is just fantastic club's wild
right it was so cool it's a dream dude I
know and it's a dream that I didn't even
have I didn't even have that dream I
didn't want to own a club I'm not gonna
be like I was concerned about the
bedroom you were concerned because you
said to me something about the big
murder you were like no it was fun but
you said to me you were like it's the
most honest room but it was you're
honestly hilarious yeah but so there's
no issues but that word honest is
usually used when like let's have an
honest conversation it's never like
right you're beautiful
babe can I be honest with you you're
beautiful
gorgeous right so
that's an interesting adjective to use
to describe the room yeah and then I
went up and it was it was awesome and
there was an energy and there was an
excitement and the room was great and it
also offered this other side of stand-up
that I think a lot of people that come
up in the small rooms don't necessarily
develop the skill set until they're on
the road which is filling space
and it was like you can learn to step on
them and that's how I came up in New
York and said boom boom boom boom boom
and then you go do 3 000 seats How Are
You Gonna Fill that yeah how you gonna
absorb that and I was watching Ron White
go up there and that's a perfect example
of just like kinetic energy you're just
watching him [__] he's like like um the
Black Panther suit you know what I mean
just like absorbing everything absorbing
everything and then push back Joe just
would never hear about me retiring and
and so then I went around
and finished all the dates that I had on
the books I got my chops back and uh but
I made a decision to retire and that's
what I did at the end of the year but
this club it's too hard to resist it's
like a warm bath man the best sound I've
ever heard the most beautiful Club
that's ever been imagined and uh you
know it was like Rogan's gift to the
comedy community into Austin you know he
didn't need that and uh he did it so
we'd all have this great place to grow
and he's such a you know a a cool part
of the comedy community you know and
generous like he's like he's like the
new version of Mitzi Shore finally we
got to check out the comedy Mothership
shout out to Joseph Rogan I mean this is
a this has been a process I saw this
thing when it was gutted the building
when it was gutted out and he was like
this is what it's gonna be and it was
just like a vision but I was like okay
then I don't know a year later I saw it
like at the halfway stage or something
then I saw it about 80 percent done and
then I hadn't seen it and then it opened
while I think we were out of town
and then you did it one night and then I
I finally got to do it uh on your night
I actually went on your night and uh
yeah he nailed it it's it's [__]
awesome it's incredible everything is
utter Perfection and it's because he's
been in comic for so many years and
finally one of us has made a club so he
knows I mean the detail even what I love
is the the main stage the fat man
right behind the curtain where the
performer you wait is a performer to go
out on stage you part the curtains and
you go out he even put a chair behind
that curtain just in a cubby so that
you're alone to collect your thoughts
right [__] that most clubs don't think
don't even like that is so specific
detailed it only a comedian who seasoned
understands and I think too it's just
been lovely for us to have a community
again which we you know we've all lost
because of moving and this and that and
it's just lovely to hang out with like
degenerates again
to be there I mean oh my God I was an
unannounced guest at your show yeah
I was [__] it was a wild reception I
mean they were awesome yeah I I that was
probably that was the craziest person
they stood up when you got out it's
crazy it was nuts dude congratulations
guy we're waiting for Ari that club is
thank you beautiful thanks thanks it's
fun everything everybody said it was too
which is uh you know the energy down
here is good right now for comedy
there's a lot of good people here and a
lot of funny people that are actually
working there which is fun too the way
that he's paying Comics it's bananas bro
bananas it's it's like it
complete Game Changer huh like I don't
know how the other clubs will react yeah
because they're in it to make money yeah
it's about the model where it's like he
it's like he doesn't want to make money
Fair he's like I'm still gonna do the
Vulcan I'm still gonna do like the creek
in the case which is the sweetest thing
which is very nice
here's the other this is the other thing
that's crazy this is
if you work at the club a lot of people
that work at the club or Comics you can
check out your shift to go do a spot
and then come back in another place in
another place that's wild yeah and then
come back in and the other place can't
be mad because Rogan will still perform
at your Venue yeah
yes he like took money from Spotify and
is glittery Distributing it to comics in
in an insane way he did
something really good for the comics he
invested in comedy he didn't invest in
himself he's got 300 000 million dollars
what's he give a [__] about he did he
made an investment for comics for you
[__] haters out there for you people
who know somebody who hates him covid
whatever the [__] guys it's all [__]
it's just fun to be in that real Club
environment yeah and everybody was enjoy
everybody came off the stage with a
smile whether they were like a door guy
or door girl doing five minutes or
someone like Ron White who was popping
in doing spots it's hot and it's fun
it's really fun it reminds me of like
the great clubs in the country where
you're like when you go to Comedy Works
in Denver Acme in Minneapolis where
you're like man that was fun a [__] is
fire it's the same kind of vibe there
like audiences that are stoked to be
there and and know how to behave and
they take their phones last night was my
first uh time in a managerial position
like I just came to hang out make sure
everything ran smooth for your show it
was wild like to be at my own club where
one of my best friends is headlining and
all my other friends are opening for him
right like this is amazing it was a
pretty [__] sick lineup I'm like this
is what's crazy incredible if you said
this 10 years ago in Austin Texas the
lineup that was on last night was insane
we've been doing that a lot though
that's what's crazy like every these
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday shows that
we've been doing out here they're just
stacked dude and then and then let's
just say highlight of my career they're
telling they're chanting the machine and
I go I'm not going to tell it and they
they start cheering it and I go all
right I'll tell it if Ron White tells
his tater salad story
people didn't even know he was up there
yeah if you're a young comic are you
gonna come to New York
and toil away in obscurity for four
years
in destitute poverty do you come here
and then compete with the best comics in
the world
for stage time which is going to be very
difficult
or do you go to a new city where the
best comic school would haven't moved
there yet and the new ones haven't
developed into it yet their stage time
and money yeah and seven clubs without
the same level of competition so if
you're a brand new comic do you go there
for four years before you come to New
York right do you go there for four or
five years before you go to La and try
to be you know in sitcoms or whatever
the [__] you want to do do you learn and
develop your craft in this place
it to me I'm like wow that is a very
intriguing possibility Club is great
though dude thank you I'm really excited
I just sit in the other room too that
was fun got a good late night or Vibe
it's got um a good late night or vibe in
the little room the big room is like uh
it's not like the main room but it's not
like the or yeah it's kind of like the
or on steroids it's just a larger or but
it's very the sound it's like it's gonna
it's a real honest room it's really good
set up great feels like a balcony from
on stage but yeah shout out to Lucy K
because uh he gave me some really good
advice about like the setup he came
while we're in the middle of
construction we changed a couple of
things because of his advice I love that
yeah we lowered the ceiling in the
little room we made the stage smaller
the stage was like four feet larger on
each side it's like why is it so big I'm
like yeah why is it so big let's go chop
it up in the little room yeah I just
said just tell me what you think and
I'll do that so wow he's like lower the
ceiling so I can't lower the ceiling to
there and then the other room like lower
it even further in the other room like
okay lower it that's funny so it gives
you a really expensive advice just say
it and I'll do it he goes
I get rid of this wall
a little bit two inches yeah yeah he
just told me what he thought it was
right he was right like he was thinking
about I was like yeah do it he's like do
it right the first time like yep yeah
yeah yeah yeah it opens because I
thought it would be okay the way it was
but it wouldn't be optimal right that's
the point like you're doing all this
construction why not make it optimal you
know it just required a lot more [__] a
lot more stuff have to be in place but
but I mean man
it's just runs so right I mean they
spared no expense and they just it's
perfect you can tell is it really yeah
yeah it's everything was so methodical
and deliberate you can tell that someone
who's been doing it as long as Joe and
pays that much attention to like
the the art and craft of stand up
was meticulous with what he wanted out
of this club taking the best elements of
The Comedy Store and and like other
places what what did he bring from the
store that is that I see in the
mothership yeah the stages you know
there's a lot of Comedy Store people
that that are at the mothership now you
know because he took a lot of great
talent yeah from behind the scenes you
know like Adam eager who's the booker
sure at the comedy store and then some
of the
some of the the wait staff and and
management too they're over there now so
it's kind of almost like a mini reunion
how high are the ceilings
pretty not like cavernous or whatever it
feels it feels right would you lose a
dove
yeah you can lose a dub yeah okay but
it's not so tall where it's too tall and
then also there's um like balcony boxes
oh interesting so there's one for VIP
and then there's one that like the Green
Room you could pop out of and catch the
show oh wow and then when you're in the
Green Room
it's sort of like this room that's the
green room for both shows so from The
Green Room you can go into the smaller
one yeah and then you can go into the
bigger one that balcony just catch the
show and then also there's lights so
there's TVs like 8K it's amazing it's so
state of the art I've been doing comedy
for 20 plus years I've been to most
clubs all over the country and the vibe
and everything about this club it's it
it's it's it's the best Cub Club in the
country but you know it's new right so
of course you know it is but I'm not
gonna take anything away from it so so
here's some pictures from the mothership
I mean the attention to detail that's
the green rooms they have two different
rooms I got this main room called the
fat man and this other room called the
little boy which is like a smaller room
holds like 75 or so and the main room
holds like 250 but just like all this
art on the wall all the attention to
detail it's really great like that's in
the Green Room a little sign right there
says Get It Together [__] that's so Joe
Rogan if you know him you know it's
called the mothership so there's like
sort of like alien artwork all over the
place and it's just like there's this
bar called mitzi's which is named after
mid Seashore at The Comedy Store and the
bar is this beautiful thing that's what
the the
from the balcony the view of the main
room looks like that's in the green room
they have this great bar and like all
these great pictures and it's just like
you know it's clean and and the lines
are great and like you know and so I
don't know I just I really had a great
time it was five sold out shows you know
and I was like man he's like Willy Wonka
you know what I mean he's got this this
amazing stuff that goes on in there and
they got all the you know so anyway my
point is this
he's not doing this to make money
you know he cares about comedy he cares
about the comedy community
he's building a reputation at his club
that he's saying to the people in this
city I am going to give you a great show
these are people I think are really
funny and they're going to be on my
stage just the green room alone is just
amazing where's the hang no you haven't
been there yet no yeah right no I need
to get out there yeah they got these two
like the two TVs for the two different
rooms the lights are in there so when
the light comes on you can change the
sound for the two different TVs
whichever room you want to listen to In
The Green Room literally thought this
out yeah yeah well of course he's a
comedian first of all walking in and
right there you see the Mother Ship me
in Austin it's a cool part of a cool
part of town and see the mother [__]
like wow
and
I guess the doorman kind of knew me or
didn't know I said hey man Joe here and
who's expecting me so I go up there and
you could feel you know it's too you
could feel the vibe in there you could
feel the energy it had a um
it's it had such an awesome energy
there's comedy clubs I go into
I've been into
where you just feel
you feel a darkness when you walk into
the Rogan Experience you just feel do
you feel that up energy like something's
going down tonight this is gonna be a
cool night and I go up these stairs and
he's got this he has this green room and
there's a small comedy club and then the
larger one from the Green Room you can
you go on the larger one you open up a
door and then you're on the balcony
where no you know no one bothers you and
you can watch the show and you feel that
that big room oh my God it's loud it's
explosive it's all different types of
people like people are flying in from
everywhere they're flying in they're
flying in from other countries to go to
the Mothership and I'm telling you it's
freaking worth it it's
it's such a cool experience
no that's seaweed I thought that was a
gator look like a gator nose
it's just seaweed did you get past that
uh Joe Rogan's Comedy Club yep
oh I actually had a question that was
cool did you get paid a lot of money I'm
about to pay or I I mean I don't wait
wait apparently the spot pay is very
high getting passed means good it means
you're like you can get booked regularly
like you're I was the club it was good
it was really intimidating what was the
scene what made it intimidating
um a lot of heavily armed security it's
already the greatest Club I've been in
I'm not just saying that
it's already
I'm already in a time capsule because I
walk in and there's the kill Tony dude
right then there's the other I don't
know who these other Comics are but you
can tell they're not really
I shouldn't say I can tell just I'm
assuming they're not far along and then
I see Howie Mandel I'm like
and then he's got these two screens you
got one screen who's on the big stage
one one screen who's on the low stage
and he's like dude let me Ace so
this is my place isn't this cool I'm
like yes this is cool how do you call
the fat man little boy though size
because fat guys are big and little boys
are small
true yeah what if one room is called
Epstein and like the other one
let's go Weinstein
I'm playing uh I'm playing Epstein
tonight oh [__] I want to get to
Weinstein though well you got to keep on
like working out and work on your craft
and Epstein and then once yeah once
you've done enough light logs then you
then you go to you get upgraded to wine
series
there's two arrows that says Epstein
lines yeah when you get there also next
time you go to the comedy Mothership let
me know if this joke World sticker is
still there I put it up here I had to
jump we should have filmed that actually
that would have been funny
that joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]